hello welcome to this video playing
shabba hang said shaaban hang shabba
hang okay um this is something yeah
united arab emirates let's see what is
coming up with Skam declined okay well i
also do this and slide bd7 don't really
know that line ok I think I have to
check check and they play this this
stuff 95mm see one I guess interesting
so i can actually preserve the bishop i
think out doing this then
okay let's let's cancel getting rid of
that pin ok I can do now I can take the
five now maybe let's do it shouldn't be
too bad pawn takes Knight takes should
be good for a slight advantage and this
I didn't even think about going directly
into Bishop f3 Wow ok ok now i have some
tactical moves n i have five in
particular i don't know if it's great
though right at five he takes you one
okay I don't have 97 if this is covered
ok but if I go a three here yeah that's
not really helpful ok so probably I mean
that this should be should be okay at
first and then send see what happens
and all neither five is possible really
is I just don't know if it is so great
okay I'm going for it takes Queen takes
Knight takes bishop b7 Queen D 1 97 wins
apiece Bishop a 327 also wins apiece so
he has to check on at five okay maybe
you rub the eight does it lose a piece
either but it's kind of a natural
yeah hey yes to take own okay okay yeah
this is me is possible it's maybe really
possible what now 927 okay he has to do
that the only move not losing the house
okay have to check so I wonder if rook C
to D 1 as I move here rook cd1 oxy d1
Bishop e3 rope t7 9797 check Wow no idea
let's try open the plundering stuff here
but try to get something
okay no I have tennis probably and now
what now
I don't have anything brilliant here
really i think i don't i don't see it at
least
this should be five maybe next yeah this
one by if I trade I don't have anything
Bishop 5c three or something like that
yeah come on check take with this yeah
man the bishop is worse is it worth
something oh really I was thinking that
this is quite useful for me I can get
the king in and okay let's see so do i
go be three here or not I think this is
helpful anyway so go there
it is a five and then taking guard looks
nice but is it enough can just about
playbook takes time war check okay one
that pawn really okay check check
check check 94 ah god damn it I just
hope that I'm still winning you will
chant bit of a shame I think it might
still win black resigns Wow ok at least
I ended this series of losses here last
couple of games were pretty awful yeah
so ok let's have a look it was a don't
unconventional opening that I don't know
too well I know that this is a line of
course but here I only unite be 60
Bishop d 695 those moves but this is
this I didn't know interesting and so I
think I have to take us pretty much
forced a check and now he gets this an
interesting wow the engine wants to do
this at school
this is the computers line into a
completely weird porn structure okay
okay the way I play it it should be ok
but nothing special it was still quite
surprised that he took with the Queen
yet it looks it looks strange to me but
he probably is just about all right yeah
here Bishop e7 my surprise me i was
thinking he goes to c5 and now i had
that night at five move the key idea was
that if he takes it wasn't why I cannot
take here because of 97 and if he takes
this trading and grabbing here like this
this there's something like the widest
vets about better him but this is the
only move yeah now we can't Rupe t1 I
don't know I am taking only 7 of course
but also possible maybe this is
ultimately not leading to much the
engine wants to take here I wasn't sure
about this I saw this line this is this
and then Bishop t6 and I was so thinking
okay hopefully there is some good
discovery here even though the engine
now says that we should be 2 is equal so
I don't have a good discovery it seems
yeah so that was the drawback of rook
cd1 I should have taken in 7 immediately
now everything is yeah i went back Ameer
d to c 1 so yet y am i mean in a good
shape with the with a pair of chips and
the way it went i think i was happy here
i have a clear plan i'm going up with my
king and undermined the structure no I'm
a better-known away 5 is a mistake
interesting wow I should have played
Bishop a three-year oh i blundered
hahaha i blundered this he could have
taken yet this is be true wow wow I
would really that would have sent me
into some some rent I can tell you that
I came so he went back and now this is
just a great position yeah here he can't
allowed this there should be six was
what I expected and now he I'm just
pressing it's not clear that white is
able to win but it gives chances of
course with the two bishops check now
Bishop of seven was possible after which
again I'm pressing but it's not clear
that i'm winning and t I'm just winning
the pawn can check your age five was
right check check yeah that wasn't good
I can just take up six why did they do
that hmm can't tell you check check you
have the king of seven he will draw this
chick check yes so I support that game
but still was a good game but I'm happy
that at least I won 11 of them okay
thanks for watching